you speak to people the time that enter
the industry that don't have that
success
what what do you think the other two
three things that you really double down
on
that helped you achieve that yeah in
addition to the work ethic and when i
talk work ethic i mean
really like being clever about how you
utilize your time work
so a lot of people at work are just not
focused
and they don't really commit themselves
to this career
so i made a commitment day one coming
into the business
that this was going to be my thing and
that i was going to amount to somebody
that was like
ego driving me so every time i talk to a
client
or a candidate it would it would be like
everything meant survival
right it was like it wasn't just like oh
maybe see
if you can grab a you know a lead
maybe see maybe it was not there was no
maybe right so it's like this
cutthroat energy i'm gonna do whatever i
need to do
to learn how to keep you on the phone
the tenacity the shamelessness
and also the focus and dedication to
making this
work making this successful having the
mindset that this
is my exit plan this is my fast track to
retirement
it's not a joke right it's this serious
dedication to the craft
of making this the vehicle the chosen
vehicle
of which i'm gonna leverage to power up
all of my financial goals